the queues are growing to cremate sri
lanka's cove with 19 victims
crematoriums are busy and mortuaries are
holding two to three times their
capacity
more than 90 people have died every day
since friday
the government called state employees
back to work last week
and eased some restrictions the
association of medical specialists
disagrees with that decision
and says the worst is yet coming
in a statement it said as medical
specialists we strongly believe
that economists and others have to be
alive in the first place
to develop the economy and no tourists
will come to our country
unless and until we are a reasonably
safe place
this mobile phone footage of hospitals
overflowing with covid19 patients
has gone viral it shows patients in
hospital gardens
on walls on corridors and icu floors
waiting for treatment the government has
denied hospitals are overcrowded
but state minister for health dr chana
jaya sumana says
the overcrowding in one of the hospitals
from the video
has been eased where there is visible
control
is the vaccine blitz launched by the
government in recent weeks
dr xiaomi seymour heads the army medical
team
supporting the health ministry trying to
vaccinate as many sri lankans as
possible
sri lanka is on a very ambitious plan
for vaccinate
above 18 everybody by end of september
so we are on the track so far
so what we are looking for as the
military is the search capacity
the vaccine campaign is making record
progress
with more than 500 000 people receiving
their jobs in a single day
and 11.2 million people or half the
population
have now received at least one dose of
the kovid 19 vaccine
almost 3 million are fully vaccinated
so everyone who has got one dose should
not be complacent
they are still liable or
vulnerable to the the virus
so till we immunize maybe
80 to 90 percent of the vulnerables we
are not safe
the head of the kovit 19 task force has
announced
people may be required to carry their
vaccination cards with them
in the future okay i was compelled to
take it like because my
children are very particular that i take
it here the procedure is done very well
so um yeah i believe it's really
important to get it
specialists here are watching closely as
the number of infections rise
with more restrictions and even curfews
to be recommended if things get worse
the numbers are not looking good for sri
lanka and
experts are warning the next few weeks
are critical
people are being urged to follow
restrictions
in order to minimize the number of
deaths here
mineral fernandez al-jazeera colombo